la peur au ventre pour ses habitants de
micropole qui ont encore été bombardée à
trois reprises la nuit dernière la
petite ville est située à peine 10 km de
la centrale nucléaire de zaporijia nous
allons tous mourir si une catastrophe
nucléaire se produise mais pas seulement
nous en ukraine la terre entière c'est
très sérieux cette centrale à six blocs
mon mari avait acheté cet appartement
parce qu'il voulait laisser quelque
chose à ses enfants il est mort et il ne
laisse rien ses enfants
la centrale nucléaire de zappos ridge à
la plus grande d'europe a été conquise
en mars par l'armée russe proche du
front de ses abords ont été plusieurs
fois bombardée ces dernières semaines
bombardements dont kiev et moscou
s'accusent mutuellement alors que les
inquiétudes min vendredi le président
russe vladimir poutine a accepté que les
inspecteurs de l'agencé internationale
d'énergie atomique fasse une visite
d'inspection la centrale mais aucune
date n'a encore été fixée
certains experts estiment que la solide
structure de la centrale devrait pour le
moment permettre d'éviter un scénario à
la tchernobyl qu'elle est très robuste
sur les chutes d'objets où les chutes
d'avion elle a une enceinte de
confinement en béton précontraint béton
armé précontraint pam m d'épaisseur on
pense qu'elle peut résister à des tirs
d'artillerie lourde
ce mardi la russie a réclamé une réunion
du conseil de sécurité des nations unies
au sujet de la centrale une démarche qui
fait espérer un possible à présent dans
la zone